[Music]
this is my gift to the
to the holy seed yeah good the holy
scene right taylor bain tacosa is
preparing for a reckoning you're such a
neater packer than i am
she is denny and a member of the fort
nelson first nation in bc she was chosen
as a youth delegate and is getting ready
to travel to rome to meet with pope
francis i still don't like that you're
going to the house of he'll repute
taylor's mom doesn't want her to go i
know
the horrific legacy of residential
schools runs deep in taylor's family her
aunts and uncles were forced to attend
as an intergenerational survivor she
knows they've been unable to talk about
what happened to them
just seeing them struggle every single
day to you know be proud of who they are
where they come from it's hard
that's what motivates me to carry on
this legacy of healing and just wanting
a better future for
for the next generations because they
deserve that
her sister morgan is traveling with her
for support i'm hoping for that apology
i'm hoping for the pope and the catholic
church to own up to what they did and to
really commit to walking this path of
reconciliation
as taylor arrives in rome so too do the
other indigenous delegates representing
first nations metis and inuit
communities
they're here for a series of meetings
with the pope
among them is elder angie creer
elder angie is representing the metis
nation of alberta and has traveled here
in hopes of healing a moment she's been
waiting for for decades
she's also catholic what does it feel
like to finally be here in rome
unbelievable
i don't know like i'm in a daze
very emotional
[Music]
as a residential school survivor the 85
year old wants to put her experience
into record as evidence for future
generations i never forget there was as
long as i live but
i knew every time i was in trouble but i
put my hand up until i said i looked two
straps
she hit me ten times bleeding all over i
never cried
[Music]
i never cried because when we cry they
like that
angie was eight years old when she and
her two younger sisters were forcibly
removed by the rcmp and taken to saint
joseph's school in fort resolution
northwest territories
the nuns and priests tried to dehumanize
the children and strip them of their
indigenous identity
even assigning angie a number she spent
a decade in residential school
so they gave
[Music]
number six that was my number
i got more lincoln's number six than i
did angie
angie wants the pope to hear about the
children who were abused and those who
never made it home
nobody wanted us
oh the white don't want you there
nothing indian don't want you nobody
wants here i got news for them
i have an identity
i've learned my mutination of alberta
[Music]
an estimated 150 000 indigenous children
were forced to attend residential
schools in canada a government system
that existed from the 1880s to 1996.
the catholic church ran about 60 percent
of those schools these institutions
aimed to eradicate the culture language
and traditions of indigenous people
for years there have been calls for
accountability
and action but they have been largely
ignored
until may 2021 when at least 200
unmarked suspected graves were found
here at the site of the former kamloops
indian residential school
it sparked a reckoning for canadians i
just know that it shook the world it
shook us
you know so many people believe that
this year wouldn't be happening had that
not happened
roseanne kasmir is the cookpee or chief
of takum loops to schweitman imagine the
children who were ripped from their
homes
and looking out for the window we met
with cook p roseanne on the fourth floor
of the former kamloops institution a few
weeks before she left for the vatican
there is a lot of pain
there's a lot of hope
there's so many messages that i'll be
taking to pope francis and for myself it
is an opportunity to really carry the
voices you know of our survivors the
impacts here of the findings of the
unmarked graves are you expecting to get
an apology from pope francis when you
were there at the vatican
absolutely not
my hope is that he comes to the columns
of schwepmeck i believe
having him here on indigenous land on
the unseated ancestral lands of the
first nations
communities of where it took place and
where it had happened would be something
that would be significant
and would have greater impact
[Music]
as daylight breaks over st peter's
basilica delegates are walking the path
of reconciliation
taylor can i just ask how are you
feeling this morning i'm looking forward
to it
over the coming days the pope is meeting
with each delegation metis
inuit
and first nations
we told our story to our pope we told
them the hardships of
the pain
the the
horrors of everything sexual
mentally and
your soul
i seen our pope
i truly believe
there is an honest person here
after each private meeting there was a
time of reflection and display of
indigenous culture outside
[Music]
during the trip delegates toured the
vatican museum inside they saw
indigenous cultural belongings and
artifacts raising the question about how
the items got there in the first place
looking at those artifacts just knowing
that some of this stuff was probably
stolen we know that from oral history so
trying to decipher you're like oh like
what which stuff was a gift and which
stuff was stolen
as indigenous people we believe
everything has a spirit
the stuff that was stolen is probably
like crying to go home
on the final day with angie in the front
row pope francis made a speech that
shocked many in the room
i ask for god's forgiveness and i want
to say to you with all my heart
i am very sorry
four simple words it's taken decades for
the head of the roman catholic church to
say
after days of hearing traumatic accounts
of residential schools and their
devastating legacy pope francis
apologized for the deplorable conduct of
some members of the catholic church
the abuse is you suffered in the lack of
respect shown for your identity he
emphasized his shame and committed to
visiting with them on canadian soil
[Music]
i'm nathan obed president of the inuit
behind
the cover-ups behind the indifference
behind the lack of justice pope francis
decided to go right through it
and decided to speak words that
first nations inuit and metis have been
longing to hear for decades i was
shocked
because you know call to action number
58 calls for the pope to make an apology
to
the indigenous people of canada
on canadian soil my heart is so full i
can hardly speak i told him
don't forget our children
and he said we won't we gotta get back
back
so much we lost
and let the world know that we are
the people of love
amen
outside with the backdrop of the vatican
an institution that tried to erase
indigenous culture and traditions
members of the delegation celebrated the
historic apology
it was incredible
to know
that i carried the messages
coming out of the vatican and
participating you know with that women's
warrior song participating in that round
dance was so uplifting and so meaningful
was that moment reconciliation in action
that was definitely a step
at a moment in reconciliation
it was about that cultural genocide that
was taken away it was about upholding
the spirituality through
the singing through the
language the culture the expression of
ceremony it was so impactful
in fort st john taylor's plane touches
down in the hours and kilometers away
from the vatican and the historic event
for taylor the apology is just but one
small step and she knows much more work
needs to be done
when i was with the pope i had expressed
to him that our people are the fastest
growing demographic in canada yet we
have the highest suicide rates and
um on the day of our final audience you
know he said those words everyone is
feeling great
when we were having dinner just hours
later we find out that a young person
from one of our communities in the north
had taken their life that person that is
no longer with us i think emphasizes the
work that that i have to do and i think
that we that we all have to do
perfect so if you want to make yourself
comfortable in there i'm going to run
upstairs and grab the mirror for all who
know elder angie career one thing is
clear right here she's a force
we traveled to grand prairie treaty 8
territory to speak with angie one month
after the pope's historic apology
angie was one of the metis delegates who
spoke with pope francis about the abuses
she faced in canada's residential school
system she's also catholic how was your
trip
when we met up with her she was at city
hall dropping off a gift to the first
female mayor metis national council
president cassidy karen was also there
angie you're the only two awake on the
plane right now go to sleep
so we all need help okay yeah
so we offered something very special for
you oh thank you
oh wow that's that's
by the pope yeah wow since she has
returned home from the vatican angie has
had a renewed sense of vigor smells like
roses
for most of her life she has felt guilty
guilty for not being able to protect her
younger sisters from the violence and
abuse inflicted on all of them by the
nuns and priests that ran the
institution they were forced to attend
and i protected them you know scars all
over my body all over me
i always protect as much as i could
but almost a lifetime later after the
pope apologized the pain she's felt has
lifted brought me
my peace i'm no longer i don't feel
guilty
and i just feel free
i've been feeling free since i come home
and that to me
i thank god for that is not i need that
i needed that
[Music]
i also feel shame i'm saying it now and
i'm repeating it sorrow and shame
the response to the pope's apology has
been mixed many think an apology is just
one step and must happen in canada to
have real significance
roseanne kasmir is the cook pee of
tacoma loops to sweat mick there are
some who don't accept the pope's apology
how do you respond to that
there is so many
that we're so proud
it does make a difference my
thing is if it makes a difference for
even one person then i've carried the
messages that i needed to
in kamloops located on takum loops to
schweitman territory situated within the
unseated ancestral lands of the
sequentic nation
grand chief joseph joe manuel is
reflecting on the past
he doesn't accept the pope's apology
no i don't you know accepting
an apology
it's a heinous crime
that should be dealt with accordingly
because there's no one above the law joe
is a survivor of the former kamloops
residential school he was a young child
when he was taken away looking back at
those days that was the only way to
survive in the residential school to
listen to all these superiors and do
what they
asked of you to do
there were some
that were rebellious that
didn't want to give up their language
i believe that those were some that
disappeared
joe's drive for justice was strengthened
by the recent indigenous delegation trip
to the vatican he feels the only way for
healing is through criminal
accountability
i wrote a letter to the honorable prime
minister justin trudeau regarding 215
unmarked graves of the camps residential
school
we want the graves dug up and examined
by professional people to find out where
they're from and how they died
every child matters
the letter goes on to ask the prime
minister to subpoena those involved joe
wants every accused staff member still
alive held responsible
so far the canadian justice system has
failed to hold the vast majority of
abusers to account in 2015 the truth and
reconciliation commission released a
report identifying more than 38 thousand
claims of abuse in residential schools
but the commission was only able to find
fewer than 50 convictions that's why i
want to use the law
i believe this is the only way that we
can
accomplish this
i can't wait to get to court
[Music]
well the holy father is
in calgary william mcgrattan is the
bishop and vice president of the
canadian conference of catholic bishops
he also believes abusers should be
brought to justice
we strongly encourage those who have
experienced either physical
or sexual abuse to come forward so the
church should not be standing in their
way
bishop mcgrattan was also at the vatican
for the apology pope francis fell short
of apologizing for the damage done by
the catholic church in terms of
colonization in terms of the cultural
genocide without that acknowledgement
how can there be real healing he does
acknowledge that historical reality that
the church was involved in this
colonization he did address it in the
sense of indignation and shame he did
make specific reference and i think in
many ways to recognize the personal
stories that he heard
when it comes to the attendance records
involving former residential schools
what is the church doing to make those
documents more accessible we understand
through the delegation that certain
records or references to those would be
found within the archives of the
offlights over in rome
here in canada
we the diocese have put together a
committee
that are helping our diocesan archivists
to be able to explain what records we
have so it's not that we don't want to
share them it's a question of how can we
share them effectively and we're trying
to make those available and is there a
timeline on that
i'm looking at a window of anywhere from
one to three years where diocese would
be able to have their records digitized
and then to make them available to the
communities
[Music]
the former kamloops residential school
was the first site to find at least 200
unmarked suspected graves now more
communities have also found sites
families still don't know if their
children are buried there
those records that are held in rome i
believe are very important in finding
the truth to the answers that we all
need to come to terms with the children
that did not make it home
in july pope francis is planning on
visiting edmonton quebec city and icalue
while in canada many indigenous leaders
including roseanne will be looking to
the pope to atone for the church's role
in colonization and cultural genocide
against indigenous people i believe it
would be an absolute travesty if he
didn't meet with our community or any of
the other first nation communities that
have had you know findings among mark
graves organizers say the pope will
visit a former residential school but
it's still unclear which one
we're going to go into outreach okay
back in alberta elder angie is at the
grand prairie friendship center an
organization she's volunteered at for
more than 40 years
[Music]
part of her road to healing has been to
help others so much so that in 2005 she
received the governor general's caring
canadian award i can forgive now
but you know
i know i'll never forget
we are the ones that were the victims
we are the ones
are healing ourselves and working
together trying to forget the past and
build on our own rights to make our own
decisions
while angie understands the pope's
apology won't undo the wounds it's given
her much-needed peace to move forward
with the next chapter of her life and i
was always be grateful
because now i have peace
and i'm free and that i think we every
one of the survivors
we all wish we have that